This is a download from BBC Learning English to find out more, visit our website.
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English, I'm Sam.
And I'm Neil. In this program we're talking all about restaurants, specifically about
tipping. That's giving money to waiting staff for the service you received.
Yes, while tipping is discretionary, which means that someone could decide whether they want to
give money or not, in most places in the UK it's an expected practice.
But have you ever thought whether money goes or who actually receives it? Do they have to pay
tax on it? Or is it just a gift? Some people think that the person who brought our food is the one
who gets the money. However, that isn't always the case. Well, before we find out more about
where our tips go, I have a question about restaurants. The highest restaurant in the world
at Massphere is in Dubai in the building known as the Burj Khalifa. But how high up is that
restaurant? Is it a 442 metres? B, 500.